actually right will be lose this game
yeah
i mean there's no way to ever push the a
pawn but even if you could black would
just give up a bishop and go after
white's h pawn and i mean now if black
goes bishop f2 check and takes h4 and
only after that takes the a6 yeah and
he's not doing this
of course it's not a must but white is
going to be making a draw this way i
think
yeah but well actually black is heading
to d3 and try to give checkmate on avon
with his rook
so also white's knight is almost trapped
yeah
with an extra minute on the clock and
yeah there we see a handshake report
gives up
the family actually takes the armageddon
well it seemed it was not a good
strategy by robert
to make a quick draw in the classical
game and go for the armageddon game was
pushing putting too much pressure on
himself
and with the extremely strange opening
choice which was not
uh
reacted so well i think by napolmiacci
because
simply won a porn eventually right yeah
it was something very strange things
were happening in this game i believe
so let's go back